[Music]
it's officially been a 30 years since
the ghost with the most beetlejuice
hit the big screen and Ichi was on the
set as the cast made another world met
[Music]
Jean and I died our house we move into
the haunted house we do not know
actually that the inhabitants have died
certainly don't know that they happen to
be inhabiting the house still even
though they're dead they don't want us
to be in their house we've moved in
we've taken over we have completely
different tastes from them from anyone
actually so we decide we have to get
them out one way or another and since
we're ghosts we figured hey let's scare
them we wreak havoc on their life
actually it's the humans haunting the
ghosts I'm kind of a wannabe ghost
we don't do a very good job until
Beetlejuice helps them he scared the
living out of a beetlejuice
it's show time Beetlejuice is kind of a
creepy little devilish funny character
he's an imp from another world a kind of
devil guy not a devil but but spirit
kind of guy know what our problem is
well he's slightly scary doesn't
necessarily mean he's mean I mean he's
definitely his bad boy you know I show
up on the set and I kind of did a
symbolic or a metaphoric kind of there's
everybody with me here and nobody went
stop doing that Mike so I just said okay
I'm gonna keep going come to think of it
I'll have any rules it's a comedy but
it's a ghost story and it's supernatural
it's gonna be unbelievably visually
interesting I think lots of interesting
bizarre things to look at you're gonna
see things in this movie you've never
seen before I think people are gonna be
mind blown they see it's a supernatural
comedy about life death of interior
design it's gonna go down in my memory
yeah this is one of those one of the
great movies that I will never work on I
think it's gonna be a great movie
[Music]